[Music]
hmm on oh my god blending up how
are you
I'm stuck I'm stuck in an elevator the
service is terrible during it alma mater
why would you go into a big building
today of all days how do you prefer I
should pay I know I'm sorry okay yeah
the last outfit for my laser hair
removal Abbey is about to get I am
Legend up in here you're going to need
us
I know you but I prepaid for the package
what am I not going to finish the
package I'm sorry I don't wear a
moustache for the apocalypse mustaches
are going to be currency soon I mean
it's going to grow back lazily hardly
works on me I know I think it's not like
the equipment and the settings more
importantly okay
okay okay it's happening we are t-minus
60 seconds so Papa's inaugurated I can't
believe this oh my god
okay okay you know what your your
elevators going to start moving we'll
meet somewhere in the middle maybe more
that you tried to grab your okay
okay I hate that spot but okay alright
you have me yeah do you don't give your
butterfly knife yeah in my other pants
good okay okay we're thirty second off
well Abby I love you I mean so much
whatever happens I love you and on the
way if you could meet you know batteries
or food I kind of forgot I forgot better
in that case 15 seconds my god ha I
remember and we learned in Krav Maga
okay
I know throat kneecaps growing see I
know Oh neat asteroid cake okay three
[Applause]
I didn't lose my elevator key four
o'clock he is working at put the lighter
Hartmann they never come down here
nothing does dinner I can't see I want
to go check it out
you're here you
today mooning painting come on daughter
I just got queer beat Jesus I'm
back - ha ha
nothing bragging about sexual assault
very much in the
football club people are just gonna be
dragging
dude she's like a wooden doll
from the fifties we're going to get
crushed now I like orange climber team
are just going to be picking on other
people being an only at the mouth
now it's hard again he's absolutely sick
he's just mentally ill it's not even
funny
[Music]
so today I'm just going to come over
still yeah and you know we'll just
Google how to Google our local
representative okay good plan
I'll be in there in like today and
hopefully okay I'll sing a little bit
louder baby for a three a two and one
[Music]